[Music]
don't forget to enter our Amazon
giftcard giveaway all you have to do is
be a subscriber like and comment
hey guys Helen Reid is the Lord of
greywater watch and the father of Meera
and Jojen Reed the head of house Reed
he's a loyal vessel of House Stark
rolling over the bag filled lands of the
neck and the crannogmen at the end of
Robert's rebellion he accompanied in the
dirt stark to the Tavor join the red
mountains of Dorne
in an attempt to rescue Lee in a Stark
he and the Edwardian survivors to the
showdown between the Northman and the
remaining Kingsguard loyal to House
Targaryen Reed first met his liege Lords
at the greater need here hall when he
was a young man while taking in the
magnifica of the tourney three Squires
all Arjun and him as crannogmen are
known to be shorter and smaller than
most men in Westeros started to beat and
curse him as a frog ear until the
anistar came to his defense there he
eventually met with the rest of the
members of House Stark present
Brandon Eddard and benjin later in the
tourney the knight of the Laughing tree
which was probably Lina herself defended
Reed's honor by jousting an defeating
the Knights of the Squires mentioned and
the only prize the mysterious Knight
asked for was the defeated Knights teach
their Squires on read would later tell
it Stern experiences to his two children
we first heard of him in season 3 while
travelling in the gift Brandon George
and talk about Howland Reed and his
relation to Ned Stark
Jojen remembers that when he told his
father about his visions of what
happened to Ned Stark it was the first
time he saw his father cry we first saw
him in season six brain and the trade
raven was a fight at the Tavor a joy
between it stark Howland Reed and for
other stark bannermen against two
members severe is the second Targaryen
skins guard Sir Arthur Dayne the sword
of the morning a Lord Commander girl'd
Hightower Howland Reed is the first to
charge in receiving a slash across the
chest by day the other stark bannermen
are killed along with Sir Gerald living
Ned Stark and deign to face each other
the two warriors briefly duel however
Dayne superior fighting skills get the
best net and he's disarmed just as Dane
is about to strike net down Holland whom
Dane Harrison was mortally wounded
earlier in the fight rushes him from
behind and steps into the back of the
neck net quickly ends Dane suffering
with a slash neck
nearly lapping his head off Howland is
badly injured but rise
rushing to check the bodies of the
fallen well net continues on into the
tower
many fans expected Holland to be of a
big importance in the final season
because kids after all the only living
man who did not learn the circuit about
Joshua parentage what a vision sir wires
sounds diary but he was actually there
at the tower of joy witnessing it
happening
and keeping the secret this entire time
however season 8 was a rush the only six
episode season and there was simply no
time for any of this but Howland Reed
might have appeared in a game of thermos
finale
Terry's trial was attended by lords and
ladies from all Westeros and there were
a few other faces that we got to see new
faces our Prince of Dorne Lord from the
Stormlands and Lord from the North all
unnamed other clothes give it away from
where they're coming except for this guy
there's a speculation that this guy
right here is Howland Reed sandwiched
between ed metallian cemetery was a
mysterious new face this new figure
conspicuously doesn't have any scheduled
Sun clothing but his not dressed as a
northerner nor a southerner which leads
some to wonder if this might be the
long-awaited character Howland Reed
Jojen and Meera Reed's father the house
Reed sits in the neck of the Westeros
cement right between the North and South
he wore a distinctive piece of clothes
over his shoulder as well as the latter
vem braces and it's similar to the one
that was worn by Holland reading brains
vision and even their swords seem to be
similar costumes are never next to the
enthroned Game of Thrones and those vein
braces appear to have the same X across
them the way both men hold their swords
is also similar however there's no
official confirmation about us and we
can just hope that the show Varner's
will eventually reel the names of
everyone who attended the Great Council
as of now what we officially know about
his character is that he's an unnamed
Lord who took part in the Great Council
of 305 AC to determine Tyrion
Lannister's fate as well as the new king
of the Seven Kingdoms along with the
rest of the council he accept the
ascension of bran Stark as the king of
the Andals the Royer and the first man
in my opinion dissonant lording greenish
letter was Howland Reed in both the
books and show the character of Howland
Reed fought alongside Ned Stark at the
Tower of joy and Jocelyn was born and
that's the only living person in
Westeros was actually there
Tower when John was born he will
definitely play a bigger role in the
bows than he did on the show I believe
he has some actual proof and escaping it
in secret until the time is right when I
think about it if this in fact was
Holland then I don't know if I'm
actually glad it was scheme or
disappointed how long should I play much
bigger role in the show especially so
because he's the only living man who was
actually there with Ned a witness John's
birth and knows everything also I don't
know how to feel about him agreeing for
brain start to be the king on the one
hand his reason brain became the
three-eyed Raven because he sent him
children George and Meera to take him to
the three-eyed Raven cave without them
brain would be dead so I guess it
doesn't make sense he'd want brain as a
king on the other hand Helen knows John
is rightful heir and yet doesn't speak
or suggests him to be the king this does
not annoy me as much as say not
suggesting Jon Snow for a king a man he
knows is the best choice to lead in a
man he knows his rightful heir and the
men so good his naming his first child
after him same now in the season 8
finale all of the sudden forgot his
words from the season 8 premiere maybe
he was convincing John yet he should
take the Iron Throne and rule the semi
kingdoms because kids its rightful heir
in the best choice however well same
kind of forgot about all of that Howland
on the other hand probably doesn't know
that everyone knows it should behind
Joshu parentage so he doesn't bring his
name up for vote
he knew Ned did not want anyone to know
and he'll the secret about it during
John's entire life so he is Ned Stark's
most loyal friend kept the secret that's
my take on it I believe he just saw
Helen read in The Game of Thrones finale
there are a few other things most fans
miss from the finale that I'd like to
talk about starting with the changes in
the opening credits the season the
opening credits have been changing to
reflect the important events to have
happened for example the floor turning
into ice says the army of the Dead
advanced south and we got to see some
changes smallest time in the series
finale we saw cracks on the main floor
in the last episode and we could see the
same in the opening credits additionally
the Lancer schedule was missing from the
throne room as then a successful road
through Cersei Lannister then we have a
nice little call baking day his victory
speech she gave to her armies they made
a reference to her season 6 speech to
the tracking
after capturing King's Landing Danny
spoke with her army and she told the
Trekkie that they killed her armies in
our assaults tore down their stone
houses sang gave her the seven kingdoms
back in season six she gave a speech to
the Trekkie
and here's what she said every call who
ever lived shows three blood riders to
fight beside a main guard his way but I
am NOT a call I will not show those
three blood riders I chose you all I
will ask more of you than any call has
asked his khalasar Billy ride the wooden
horses across the black salt sea I look
at my enemies in their iron suits and
tear down their stone houses it will
give me the Seven Kingdoms the gates
khal drogo promised me before the matter
of the mountains
the Dothraki cheered back then just as
they're cheering now in the finale it
was a nice callback but also reminder
that the writing has gone really
downhill they seem that we are all her
blood riders then they're Khaleesi
skilled and they just pack up and leave
like it's not their business when in
fact all thousands of them have sacred
vow as what writers to avenge Rekha
Lisa's death instead of killing Jon Snow
ravaging and pillaging Westeros while
avenging Danny they just disappeared
very much for the quality writing
disappeared from the final season in the
finale so disappointing there was this
one scene that they really liked the
parallel between Jon Snow in it stark
tyrion tried his best to explain why it
was so important for Jon to eliminate
the biggest threat to the people however
John did not want to listen the trees
and tyrion is suggesting he stays loyal
to his queen and goes on to leave the
room that's when three mentioned Jon
sisters it all genres sisters did not
bend the knee and have no intention to
do so and then he would execute them in
the future and that's when Jon decided
to kill Danny that's when he realized he
would have to kill the any of he wanted
to see his sisters led this scene was
similar to the scene between very
Senate's dark Neville's rotting in
dungeons that he did not care about his
life very suggested if he kept
information about your his parentage a
secret and instead say that he's a lying
traitor he would be given a chance to
take the black enjoy the Nights Watch
but Honorable Ned Stark said no that's a
very says Ned what of your daughter's
life my lord
both Ned and Jon took tough decisions to
make sure that their family survived
sacrificing honor and loyalty is for the
greater good of their family next to
here is the other Ahai prophecy kind of
being fulfilled
according to legend sastra high joy
sword to his wife Neeson is as hard to
create a light bringer which was the red
sword of Heroes many fans were expecting
this to happen as they considered just
now to be Azra high and that would make
Dany Targaryen in Sinisa however the
scene did not perfectly match the
prophecy as nice as nice as death
resulted in the creation of light
bringer which was used to defeat the
darkness well then is death tended the
darkness that would have spread across
the world if Danny had continued doing
what she did in his landing there are
many more nights callbacks and easter
eggs the finale had but these are the
most notable ones for example it's also
interesting that Sabrina tower becomes
Lord Commander of the Kingsguard just
like her ancestors sir Duncan the tall
census crown highly resembling sources
crown is also quite interesting
throughout the series 15 states are
trying to replicate Cersei style and it
represented how she was learning from
Cersei and we got one last example of it
as the crown that was placed on senses
head was similar to the crown we saw at
her Cersei became the Queen finally even
though the ending itself was so
disappointing to me it did have a nice
parallel to the first scene of a series
the show ends with Jon going north of
the wall with tormund another wildlings
the scene was shot in the same way the
pilot was shot fun fact is that here we
were supposed to see gentlemen and Jorah
before the showrunner Celeste mama
decided to rather heavy Jorah killed
even the part where they went past the
wall was filmed in the same way in
conclusion the finale was probably the
worst episode of the show but there were
a few nights callbacks and parallels
please let me know your thoughts about
all of this in the comment section down
below do you think this unnamed Lord was
Helen Reid or was it just some random
Lord from the rich or the Riverlands and
as always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace